Yeah. I don't understand why you haven't been fired from that.
Why you weren't fired?
I don't understand how I still live with him.
If you think the house smells weird, that's because he us on the balcony.
We are wondering why.
You, that it really is a fair, I mean like Baron whole says, like,
I don't understand a lot of people say, I don't understand why she is with me.
Yeah. This is like.
Like Donald Trump. Yeah. We don't get why people are voting for you. And
we just don't understand what's happening. Yeah. I don't care.
And you're the dumb public. This look, we like doing it.
Yeah.
That's actually,
that's the perfect way to explain it because I don't even think the dump public
knows exactly what they love about him. They can't, they can't.
What the problem is you being with Bobby says one,
every guy you've been with before you have a horrible taste in men,
like they must be monsters. Okay. You must've been with like
Satan and then you're just like, Oh, somebody would horrible feet.
That's all. This is like,
if Bobby's like a blessing, man.
Now he is only because people,
anybody else that I've dated in the past were just so textbook.
Perfect and boring.
You and those girls that were kidnapped for 10 years in Cleveland,
the only ones that would come,
they come back to me kidnapped Bobby. Here's my Prince charming.
I like the little bit of unpredictability in my life.
And I like good stories to tell. And in my law,
and I've been in rock long relationships with very normal people in the past.
And I just always found myself bored out of my mind by myself,
like self entertaining.
I questioned that I need to see a dossier of like your previous boyfriend.
No, she,
the last guy she dated before me was a Spanish professional
soccer player. He's on [inaudible] he's on FIFA.
You played with him before? Never. Okay.
So you thought you wanted to be with somebody that wouldn't cheat on you then?
Cause he was cheating on you. Listen, if he's a professional soccer player,
he was getting a lot of horse. Okay.
That wasn't something that I was saying. Yeah.
I mean, it's not like.
Well, he really was getting a lot of books.
Keep reminding him how much he was getting a lot of books. You understand?
I'm not unrealistic. I mean, I was kind of, it, it was,
it was the lasted for a year and a half. That was sorta open. So sorta nod.
But those guys are very like machismo.
So they don't want you to hook up with other people.
When I started dating here, they were, he went crazy. Well,
yeah. He goes, is he the guy.
From hangover? You really sent that message.
Yeah.
No. He thought he said, Khalilah, you are losing your mind.
I think you need to like enter a mental institution because imagine you don't
know who I am at all. Yeah.
You're leaving. You're leaving me for this guy.
And then you just see a photo of a small fat,
disgusting looking Asian dude.
You can, there's probably six more things you could say,
but I totally get it. Yeah. Cause he's like a professional athlete and body look
[inaudible] he can't believe it. And he saw a photo of me.
Can I tell you something? This is the only reason why she did that.
Like at first she didn't really like you,
she just wanted to the biggest you to him ever. Let me see.
Let me find the most disgusting. And then what happened was she was like, yeah,
see something right now.
[inaudible] you grew on her. Like somebody drew you.
I mean, look at your face. Look how offended he got
the ugliest black dude I've ever seen. Anyway, let's move on.
So we're doing the podcast. I appreciate it. I'm just doing the podcast.
Can you just admit to him that that was, but you know what I mean?
Ask her why she's dating me.
We just did. I just answered all the questions.
Why she wanted to get back at her professional life
because you grew on her. It's her shadow. This was like,
you know what she said to herself? You know what?
I don't need attractive anymore. Yeah. I don't need tall.
I don't need anybody that can protect me in an alley.
I don't need anybody that could get things off the top shelf.
I don't need anyone that knows how to use a toilet.
Yeah. Just say I had surgery four days ago and not
once. Has he so much has taken care of me for an hour? He's imperfect.
Well, I would just say this right now. And that's so first of all, I come home.
Right? And there's her mom,
her sister were ex um, guy that she used to see. But then her best friend,
my best friend, Jessica.
Oh, you know that ugly Korean girl you just saw earlier. She wasn't that ugly.
Come on, moon, face some moon face.
She was here trying to eat her butt.
Yeah. He wants to desperately experiment for them. He's never eaten.
It's like, they're like girls spending the night and I'm like, so I slept there.
Slept there. Yeah. So our whole family is here.
You've dated a Filipina, you know, just that we come in. It's a lot of family.
And so we were all spread out in the room. They were all taking care of me.
So you know how it goes, Eric, I got.
Steve's moving in right now. So you're saying.
Steve needs to live here. But I think he likes to live like a communist.
No, no, no. Steve's a survivor. He's like a Roach.
You could pick him up and put him anywhere and he'll set up base camp.
That's just how he is. He's leaves ready for the zombie apocalypse.
A lot. Like my dad, my dad had us,
we lived in San Diego and he had a store in Sacramento. Right.
So he would drive every other week to Sacramento and just stay awake.
What kind of a store? We own clothing stores back in the eighties. Really?
What kind of clothes? It's fashion for women. It was called fashion gal.
Ooh.
Yeah. I love it. Did you have to work at the store sometimes? Yeah.
God really. My dad and my uncles owned 75 at one point. Wow.
What the?
So what happened to all of that family? Money? Bankrupt.
Oh, but so my brother and I, one day go,
we go during the summer, we got dad. We're going to drive up there with you.
Cause he had been for years, he was driving up there every other week.
It turned out it was a swap meet. I'm not kidding you right now, dude,
we went to this apartment where he lived. Right? No furniture,
not anything, a little like Korean, Matt, no blanket.
Right? And a little like one of those plugin stoves,
that's all that was in there. That's how he was living. He had electricity on.
Yeah. He had electricity on, but.
Like in retrospect.
That's what my brother is. My brother and my mom is the fancy one.
That's where I take, like, she goes, Oh we make Gabby gazebo this summer.
So she made a gazebo.
She hired somebody down. We've got a koi fish farm. Like she loves like that.
That's why your dad needed a place. That it was just like,
you know your mom free, you know? Just like, no. Yeah,
no furniture.
But what did it? My dad, because back then my dad didn't he didn't,
he doesn't watch TV. He's not, he's never seen a TV show. Has he seen you on TV?
Yeah. He's been on TV. Oh, Oh yeah. He was on mad TV a bunch of times. Yeah.
He was getting residual checks. She had to sign up for AFTRA. But union sag.
Your dad say he was that's how much we had him on.
But my dad doesn't like music. Wow. He didn't name a Beatles song.
I don't know who who's. Bob. Dylan. I don't know.
He doesn't know anything you say who's Tom Hanks. I don't know. He doesn't,
he doesn't know what a movie is.
So he probably didn't even know what he was doing saying is,
is that what the was he doing every night by himself?
In a matte, in an, an like apartment with no furniture.
All he was checking off like, Oh you think so?
But it's just so sad to think about that. No, he needed it.
I totally get it. He had these crazy kids, but back then you guys were insane.
You were young. His wife was spending all his money. Yeah, you're right.
Maybe that was it. And then he just needed to go. I find it like a,
like a man cave. You know B.
You also could have had things that we don't not even aware of.
Probably has another family. Oh my God.
What would you do if you found out brothers and sisters?
All Koreans look the same anyway. So this could be.
You look the same.
Are you getting that on camera? Yeah, he's got, he's got racism on.
Oh, it's loud. And we don't, you know,
that's the only people get here your before the cameras start rolling.
My friend. Let me say something right now.
Which stereotypes w you know, that serotype Asian people look alike. Yeah.
Do we?
Yes. But how many,
you know, like, so what I'm saying? Oh, well, all right, dude.
So have you been to the airport? Walk by an Asian guy? Is that Bobby?
You thought that one time or you being real? I was
like Bobby. Oh. Oh really? And it was like a little grandma,
same body shape. You know what I mean? But I'm saying there's a similarity.
There is similarities. That's how you can go. Well, first of all,
could you pick a Korean out of a bunch of people? What do you mean?
Like if you saw like a group of people, you could go, Oh, that person's Korean.
You know why?
Because there's distinct looking things that are distinctly Korean.
That's why you can go. Oh, that guy's Korean. Yeah.
But I could also go that's Sally, the Korean,
the Korean sometimes all the time.
not what if they're all dressed the same? I don't know. Addition still, like,
I've never looked at Steven noon and went Steve. I mean, my brother, you know,
or I never looked at Daniel Dae, Kim, I go, is that sung Kang.
Mm mm. Sometimes. Yeah.
But definitely you don't look any like any, any black or whatever.
Yeah. Or like.
Do you fight TSA the way he does? Why don't you get TSA pre.
I don't have that. Oh, that's because you have to fly the same airline. Okay.
I'm going to do that.
[Inaudible].
Told me how to treat TSA and I fight them every time.
This associated, when we're in the airport,
I go into a completely separate line because I don't even want it.
Pretend like, I'll tell you why. Here we go.
You're not a police officer. Yeah. Don't get me started.
And I'm going to say this, all right. This question,
after they see your ticket and your ID,
you'll be like putting your stuff on that little belt thing. Right.
And they'll go, some Sam, some stranger will go, where are you going, sir?
And I don't answer them. It's none of your business. I know you already saw my.
I'm not answering you.
All the I had to go through to get to this point. Like, I'm with you. You know,
I don't, Oh, I hate him. I was at a Chicago. And like,
so for some reason to align with a little messed up. So they had,
and the legislature, he was yelling at us, you know, she was like, you know,
y'all got him out, but it just going on and on. And I was like, um,
this is a customer service business. Okay. Like w and then there was, luckily,
there was this white guy there in a suit. And he was like,
I need to see this chick manager. So the manager comes over and he,
and her name was cookie. Of course. I was like, wow, like the show.
And she was just acting up. And I said to the guy, I said,
let's not act like this is the first time you've got a complaint about her
attitude. Okay. And they, you know, he was just like, trying not to be like,
I was like, come on, like, like learn some manners, you know? Like,
I feel like that's not a government assigned job. Okay.
You actually filled out an application and was like, I want to do this job.
And it's like, dude, it's like, they have one application for the post office,
DMV, uh, parking enforcement and TSA.
And then they just assign them because they all had the same ridiculous,
another thing.
Really their fault. Right. It's like,
they probably are told all these things about rules and you know how
to look for, you know what I mean, ISIS?
I mean, and all these things, a million people go through the airport.
How many times do you think they'd stop a terrorist? What,
how many times do you think they stop a terrorist at lax?
Because that will be on the news. We let, we found a terrorist. No,
never has happened out of 10 million people. There's probably one person that.
The route they're going to take the next time, because when they did nine,
11 was such a shock because no one had ever really done that before.
Just steal our planes and use our planes against us,
which I've said this before was a genius. Yeah.
Yeah. But not wrong and evil, but not in the worst thing ever,
but not in the long run. And it does. It's not like, like if your eyes,
let me tell you that if ISIS,
this would be the stupidest thing ever if I just did get a bomb and blew up some
city or anything like that, all they would do is poke the bear.
And then it would be the only reason why we don't go over there and just ransack
the place as it is, is because we police ourselves. You know, we got the dog,
we got people going, no, we don't want any kids to die.
We don't want any families to die. We don't want any soldiers to die.
If they killed hundreds of thousands of people,
all that would mean it would just be, this shouldn't be over like this,
because we would be like, Hiroshima, Nagasaki. Yeah. We don't around.
We don't around when it comes to.
We did, we, what we did after nine 11, wasn't enough. Let's just,
I'm just saying what we did after nine 11,
the response had made no absolute sense.
We took us and be police ourselves.
So I'm not getting what you're saying. So what you're saying right now is,
is that if there was even a bigger, like they killed a hundred thousand people,
then what you're saying that our response would be devastating to them.
Yes. I don't think so. No, because we would have the, we would have the okay.
Cause even that.
No, but just the, here's the thing though. We had the okay.
To go into Afghanistan to find Osama bin Laden. Right.
Cause that's what happened. He was in charge of nine 11.
Right. But instead we went into a country. Right.
And then we took out Saddam Hussein who had nothing to do with nine 11.
So what I'm saying is, is that regardless of what they do to us,
our response is probably going to be,
they're not going to make any sense.
Look, this is, this is about, about Homeland security.
I'm more conservative than I am liberal. Cause I liken it to like,
if we're playing basketball on the yard and we're getting serious. Yeah.
There's always a guy that's like, man. Y'all, I'm going to go to my trunk.
You know? And back in the hood,
that just means this guy's got a gun in his trunk. Right. Okay.
Now the difference between the liberal and a conservative,
the liberal is going to let him get to the trunk and kill three people and then
do something about it. The conservative is going to be like, uh,
you're not getting to the trunk. We're going to beat your right here.
Now check this out. There may not be a gun in the trunk. Right.
But the action was taken. Yeah.
That's the difference between the two conservative.
The conservative would go to somebody that had nothing to do with the situation.
So now I'm gonna see him was the gun. He was claiming that he had weapons.
Isn't a,
why we have ISIS in the first place is because we de stab stabilize that region.
There was a civil war. We needed stabilized really to create ISIS.
Well, that's just a by-product of.
And the worst by-product that we can imagine, Bobby. Yeah.
We've been over to that place. We've been over to these places.
They don't know how to treat their own people. They're, it's ridiculous.
Like Egypt should be bulldozed. Okay.
Like it's like they don't follow traffic law.
They don't follow traffic laws.
Goats get out of buses in the middle of the street.
[Inaudible].
Stay in like some of these places,
all the oil money is going to like one family. And they're not,
they're not helping their own people. Like that. is the thing that money.
Well funded. They fund, right. These terrorist activities
is that everyone's included. Just listen, everyone's in cahoots. Right.
And I believe right.
That if we were attacked our response,
wouldn't be not my point. I'm trying to make to you,
is this what you're trying to convince me?
We were attacked. There would be no,
w w it would galvanize everybody like it did after nine 11.
What we did was we did something that had nothing to do.
Does it matter what extra does it matter? But, but that was still the mandate.
Given go do something. What you're saying is what they did. Wasn't proper. Okay.
I'm telling you though. All right. So before that country was like,
ISIS attacks us. Right. We will do something.
Because it's right now, it probably needs you because now you know what?
You need to get China because China and North Korea,
[inaudible] missing the point. I'm not missing anything.
Well, I'm telling you if something bad happens,
the whole country is going to be like, all right,
we're okay with you doing whatever. Like,
we'll need to look at what happened in like, in, the last drop, a bomb on Iran.
If they held him, everyone from Belgium yet.
I think they did the brothers.
Yeah. Paris, like all these things. It's like when they can't, when,
when like that happens, those people always end up dead.
The first time I've ever seen somebody not end up dead is that guy from the
Boston marathon.
Usually the cops.
And the government, you know what I call them. They don't around with.
They just don't around with things like that.
No, he's evil. And this is with, right? Because when we're rolling stones,
put them on the cover of the book of magazine and, and you know,
he has women followers. And how.
Make them look like a rock star with Jeffrey.
And what does this say? This he's a evil little. And he deserve to die.
He's cute. A fact. Which one though,
do you think he's cute? You're talking about the younger one.
Not supporting him saying that. Yeah.
I'm not saying to anything,
but that's how people are going to misconstrue that if he wasn't a terrorist,
that's suck. His Dick. Bobby thinks the guy's cute. He said,
he's okay with terrorism. That's what, that's how people will do it.
Usually those people end up dead. You know,
when you hear about a shooter or something, the next day, it's like the guy,
the shooter dies every time Colin buying. Am I going to get in trouble?
That's our knife is cute. No, he has a girl club. He wasn't a terrorist.
This happens all the time.
Why are you talking about it? Hey man, bro, I'm singing a song in the beginning.
You don't interrupt me until I introduce you, man.
[inaudible] we got Khalilah, my beautiful Kalila,
my beautiful Island queen from the mud rivers. Of course,
for the Philippines. We've got, um, a little piece of mud river,
two dimensional face. Gilbert. Can't see me. Yeah. He goes to the side.
He disappears. It's like a line. Is that Brown line.
Great character on Charlie Brown. We have right here.
Richard Ramirez as bands. Now he's back nights. Tucker's back nights.
Docker actually don't work. How he's in the club
and we got a he's accomplished.
I accomplished George chemo. That's how you pronounce it. And um, we got,
um, a very special because we've had them before.
I think this is the first time we've, you know,
we've used ASA a couple of times, but this is his, um, fat Lando.
There's a new movie called you already caught fat star Wars and Lando and
I'm fat Lando. There's going to be your fat Yoda.
[inaudible] how about we watch together, bro? It's good. It's good. It's good.
I asked for it. I asked her. Yeah.
Um, so we got Eric Griffin back and uh,
he's on a new television program called I'm dying up here and it's on
Showtime and uh.
Comes out July 7th. Know we're going to do that. dude. I'm sorry.
Don't load. It's so unorganized. And I'm not sure.
That's the thing in the chaos intern. Yeah.
This is structured river over here. I don't know what we're doing here.
Yeah. And um, when I get my beard transplant,
which is what I'm going to do, I'm going to use you.
I'm going to use your knuckle Harris. I mean, what the.
You wouldn't [inaudible] mustache. You have on your
[inaudible]. Let me finish. No, I do look like you haven't evolved fully.
You know what I mean? No, this is like right before the, a werewolf movie,
when a guy goes rotten, you know,
you don't want to shave that or wax it I've tried. And it turns into your.
Yeah. Yeah. Oh my God. It's so weird.
I've just noticed that it's really bad because you're such a big guy that
there's just so much to look at. Here we go. So I just, I slowly noticed.
Bobby per capita you're way fatter. You know what I mean? It wouldn't mean like,
if you did like the abortion proportionally. Yeah.
You're just like, okay, see, this is.
Make fun of me for my dog. Cause this is 1950s dog.
A water hose is going to come out next.
But over time she'll know which, uh, which battles to, you know,
you've got to pick and choose your battles.
With battles so she could pick with me.
But the video game thing, you don't. How, how long has it been?
Since you've heard anything about the video games, he doesn't play them anymore.
Good ones. You got to play in donkey,
Kong and in here.
Okay. Do you scream like him when he plays? Yes. No you.
Don't? No, because I hear you. Okay.
Oh my God, baby. He screams louder than me.
We're having a great time. I know how much we miss Bobby, but you know what?
He is a better human being.
I can't play destiny with you because I'll tell you why. Okay. I, I,
I gain resentment, deep resentment.
I gain, um, I start like kids, you know?
Cause there's kids I play with on destiny,
them yelling at me and tell me what to do. It was like, literally kind of going,
what the am I doing?
Then when we started playing, it was just you and I, and we were like, Oh,
we got to get somebody else. So we got Steven. And then we got like, Oh,
that's when Craig came in. We started to get all these people.
But once we started expanding into like people,
we don't know I'm right there with you.
Yeah. But here's the thing you guys suck. Yeah. But
did you ever win this one? Really
painful client software? I know.
But the fun of it was.
It was the comradery of it, but here's a 6:00 AM in the morning.
We played for seven hours ever been to the lighthouse. No, I'm never going to.
Write. Why? What do you want to live.
Like that? I listen. I totally understand what you're saying.
I know I get as equally as frustrated with just game, I'm playing and I'm like,
they're doing like trials or some. And I'm like, I hate this.
I'm not having fun.
Like I'm literally not having fun because there's no way to get better at it.
Like I don't care. Like I changed controllers,
different guns because I like playing with you guys.
That's what it's all about. Yeah. The Bobby don't you remember?
We became friends because we were in the middle East playing
X-Box on the road.
Can you guys find a different interactive game other than destiny,
where they're going to do the screaming and we're going to do a podcast
together. I see that. I see that
[inaudible] but I'm not bitter.
I remember we went to all things comedy together. I know
I was in the car when you made the phone call and I told you to go to that
meeting and you didn't the second time around, whatever. Anyway,
it was done as the mix. Did you buy a mic?
Oh see this is okay, baby, baby, baby, baby, baby,
baby. You are the best thing to happen to this guy here.
You guys recognize that him and I, this room,
you think this room would look like this. It would be crazy in here.
We wouldn't even be doing the pocket.
I still think that you guys should do a podcast together. And I've always said,
what's your, what's your pity podcast. Oh, wow.
What did she mean? The Sylvia Plath references and all this
[inaudible].
Listen to me, man. Listen, but you know what? At the end, Eric,
at the end of the day, right? Like, you know, when I first met you,
I'm like who the is this piece of? And I saw you perform in the middle East.
We went to the middle East when Sebastian and I met.
And a single tear came down your, your cheek and I no porn.
And he couldn't make the crowd laugh.
I'm just teasing. He was killing. You know how he is. He just,
he never thinks he can do well. But anyway, um.
I saw you that years ago,
it was 10 years ago and I saw you go off and I was like this guys,
you know? And we've been friends since then know, um,
I'm really just blessed to have you in my life.
You're invited to all of our life events. Should we have, should we have one?
So she's gonna be everywhere. Huh? And congratulations.
Congratulations on the project you have with Pauly shore.
Congratulations on that.
Oh, you project, you are so full of. Hate you. Yeah, he's doing.
He's going to do a YouTube video with Paula. Paula has come up to.
Me three times. I know. I know.
But he's come up to me three times as if we haven't had the conversation
already. I know because he's afraid. He's afraid that he can't get, you know,
he called me. He called me. Yeah. Right. First of all,
I was in a parking lot and he, he,
he like was trying to act like he was mad about him dying up here. He was like,
you know, and I said, Paula, you're not as good of an actor. Yeah.
I know you liked the show stop. So he told me about the thing.
Then he emailed me. I said, that was great, dude. I'll do it. I hit up Bobby.
I think Bobby tell me about this thing. And he goes, you have to do it
politically. But I still think it's funny with all the people that are anymore.
Isn't it? It's what he does play the political game. No, not,
it's not like he does it. You know what I mean? This guy, South Korea over here.
I know. But um,
I see Paulie at the spa and I'm literally getting to the point where it's like,
if I see him, I'm going to avoid him.
But he lied because he says Chinese people in a song.
So I walk into those Chinese people,
the wonderful people in the world, and there's all these Koreans uncomfortable.
And then he'll walk up to a Korean man. He doesn't know and slap him in the.
Why would he slap him in the it's crazy? And I go,
you're going to get in trouble. He goes, I never did,
but in Korea they'd kill me. But here we are in a Mac.
I did what the foster, he called me one time.
This was like a couple of years ago to go to the Gordon Ramsey, uh, iron chef,
whatever that definitely does. So we're sitting in like, we're, we're just,
we're eating food, you know? And um,
Polly's getting his food and he goes over to Gordon Ramsey.
He's not supposed to do this because he's like Gordy,
Gordy, this isn't cooked. Right.
And then it comes over to us and I look at the camera and I go,
you invited Pauly shore.
You thought he was going to sit down and have a pleasant meal? Yeah. Like,
come on, man.
Can I tell you the most embarrassing thing I ever saw him do?
What's that we were in San Diego and we were at Jamba juice. This is the old,
this is when juice. Like there was only Jamba juice.
They didn't have all the fancy, fancy, good now. Right.
But now it was Jamba juice.
So there was a line out the door and he just cuts to the
front. Right. And poly shad it.
And he cuts and they served them while I waited in line.
Actually anyone can do that. But listen, I.
Attitude. I'm going to say this right now. Okay.
You literally version of me. All right. Oh no. Not at all.
You don't look like.
[Inaudible].
Funny and charming. What? Yeah. Yeah. Bobby. I know what I'm saying.
Yeah, you do. Right. And I know what I'm working with and we're the same. No,
not really. Why we pulled blue.
We both played the video games like 12 year olds, but I'm tall.
[Inaudible]. Yeah, but that can change that. But I can,
I did three years ago. I know, but I can,
but I can always go back. You're always going to be
so mad.
I am so angry right now. But the thing is, is that, um, I know,
but I also want to say, this is how I met Eric Griffin.
How I got to know him. How long? Yeah. Okay. So, um, I met our,
met our friend or our good friend or my dad said, Hey,
do you want to play the middle East with you?
Eric Griffin and Sebastian Maniscalco. And I said, um, you just farted it. Yeah.
This is, this is what I'm saying. Okay. I'm not going to, it's a,
it's a gas, it's a gas.
I'm not going to clutch it in and keep it in my body. Will you keep it?
Everything else in that box?
[inaudible] yeah.
No, I don't know who he is. I mean, I had met him once before.
I did tell him about how I acted during this is so embarrassing.
Remember that one show we're on their head the first time we ever met. Yeah.
You got to set this up and I want, you want to say this, right? I don't know.
Was I almost killed? Was I mad TV at the time.
But I don't even remember, but you were the biggest Dick. Okay.
It tell him what a crazy person. So.
First of all, he comes to this show.
We get this great show out in Newport beach. We were paying,
we were paying comics in the city, a thousand dollars to come do a show.
He comes and he's a nightmare from the beginning to the end,
like the biggest diva I've ever.
Met. What I do. You were just.
Doing all kinds of. You were like, you know, it was like, get my car.
And yeah,
he was just like complaining the whole time about the show where these people
hate me. I don't want to be here. This is ridiculous. How dare you? He was like,
how dare I met a man, booked me in this.
He was going on and on about the show. Just the biggest, worst diva ever.
You know? And I had.
To call them at like a met,
you need to come down here because I'm about to kill Bobby Lee.
He did not like me.
But I didn't know who he was. You know? I was like,
I didn't get it hit me. I thought he was the guy from digital loan,
this ugly guy. You know what I mean? You're wearing the glasses. And then,
you know, the junior classes of the nose that they have,
I thought he was wearing one of those things.
You know that the little thing that they do at the thing.
So what were you guys' conversations? Do you guys even talk? No, he was like,
come on, man. Don't act like that. I'm like, you, man. I wasn't, I was a crazy,
he was crazy. I was talking crazy. Sober, sober, Whoa, God, you.
Just have diva. Tennis is he still has diva.
Oh God don't even get me started.
You don't want to hate about you to this day. It's like, you don't communicate.
Properly. Like I have.
To text you a thousand times for you to get back to me.
You never answer your phone. Your voicemail is always full. You know? How,
how does your, do you have another phone? You.
Know how people get in contact? How they have to call you?
The manager and agent have to call you.
Alan bilber are having him are having him on a podcast on Wednesday.
They didn't contact him.
They contacted contacted me anything that he had anytime he has to be anywhere
it's through me because he will not.
Let me ask you a question. Have you ever heard of Ronan?
Look at me right now. Right now. I'm gonna ask you a question.
Have you ever
[inaudible] have you heard of Ronan? Ronan's dry cleaning at best.
Right? A master list samurai. All right.
So what I am is I'm wandering through these listening in Japan.
I have a sword and I'm scratching my back and I'm walking through these dirt
like pathways and I'm just a wandering samurai,
just longing for a home. Okay. And that's what I am.
You have friends. Okay.
They want to be in your life and you want to react.
But it frustrates me when you're asked, don't call.
I hate that. That's fine. Because the things that you want,
I know what you want. Yeah, you do. No, you don't get back on destiny.
There's a new deal.
I will defend him because I see your messages pop up.
And you get the [inaudible].
He does it a thousand times until I answer. Right.
So I know what you're that's all right.
The middle East. Go on. Okay. So then.
I did that, right. And then,
so I go to the middle East and I would Sebastian who's a dear friend.
And I literally just, we, I saw Eric Griffin perform very,
for the very first time on stage. And I literally watched him and I said,
this was years ago, like a decade ago, right? No, no. It's.
Not that long ago. It was like five or six years ago.
No, it's of the long run. It's not.
Because I started in 2003.
All right. So five, six years ago. And I saw him for the first time and I said,
this guy is really legitimately funny. Well,
and he doesn't look like some, just shut the up out of the story though.
I know we're going to get to that, but you shut the up. All right. All right.
And I literally, cause he doesn't look like he is going to be that funny.
When you see him, you know what, man, what are you talking about?
This is not comedy supposed to look now because now I can put that ugly face
into your comedy. And I'm like, okay, now I get how the packaging works. Right.
But at the time I'm like that packaging is so awful. It's like.
It's like, like it's like a elephant.
And then they put glasses on it and they put it out. You know what I mean?
So it's like, but now I'm like.
Good. So Matt, how, how I blasted him?
So I looked at Sebastian. I said, this guy is,
and then we legitimately became friends. We went to Bahrain, um,
Alba Dhabi. We went to Beirut. Well.
The story, okay. Bobby had bombed so bad.
He thought it was the crowd. You know what I mean? He was like, wow,
these people just don't get comedy. And then I was awful.
This is what you really said to me. He didn't tell the story. Right.
It goes up to me. He said, when I saw you on stage and what you did,
a single tear came down my face. We had a good time.
X-Box and we started playing FIFA. And that was what we did. We played FIFA.
This is why this has happened to me.
One time I was at the airport and they have like,
you know how they have different lines. Okay.
So they had this like TSA pre line. Okay. I'm going to TSA pre line.
Now it's getting kind of long. Everybody has TSA pre now. So ain't even special.
But there's these two old people. And I saw the tickets. Yeah. I knew that.
And they were trying to cut and I'm looking around, everybody's got an attitude.
Everybody's like, Oh. And I say, I go, okay, I'm going to be the only one.
So you go put this all on me. Yeah. I had to go, excuse me,
you in the wrong place, you need to move. It's like, I hate that's why?
Cause people don't want to, you know what you put in your, say anything.
At that TSA? Uh, pocket posi. Wait, why do you know? Why? Why is that?
Cause they don't know what it is through the scanner.
So it always gets opened up. Okay.
And then they had to pull it out.
Okay. And who's that embarrassing?
[inaudible].
It's sticky because of me. Right. But he has to pick.
Now my question is you should make a mold of your Dick and you should
make the Lyla possible pocket.
Or you guys should sell their Bobby's Dick. You have so many like stuff.
You guys should send us a Dick maker. maker. Oh Bobby.
That's why you can make 10 of Bobby's.
[inaudible] just take a bath. I take it back. I'm sure. An. Yeah. Bobby,
this is the big you. This is your,
I mean imagine. Yeah. It's light skin.
Tone too. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. We have to dip this in mustard.
And he said that on the stage the other day,
what what'd you say that looked like Bobby looks like, you know the honey bottle
with a bear honey Bible. But it's filled.
He said that in front of a crowd today. I said,
Bobby looks like if some Asian kids peed in the snow,
then they made a snowman out of bachelor. Did I attack you? What'd I say,
don't try to own camera right now. I'm trying to figure out, Oh wow.
This is what he does. This is what he does. This is what he does.
He's the worst. I say that you don't look human. You look like him.
Burton drew you.
Every other episode we've had on tiger belly. He said something about my gosh.
How about the billboard in times square. Yeah.
Yeah. But your billboard would be on a hot dog stand because
it would be so little of a question. Are you hungry?
Let's go eat. You want to go eat barbecue? Yeah.
Bobby Griffin, what the is that second city dude
is that brought to you by stamps.com.
Hey tag your belly fam.
I'm curious about what you think about cultural appropriation and how people say
it's a form of racism. I see social justice work.